yeah is
girl it is what it is okay they want
good looks that's the first thing they
someone that they attracted to so guys
you have heard the sisters inshallah
you've heard what they had to say uh we
didn't we was in another room uh and we
are going to get them to send us their
results uh halfway through this so we
don't want to know El so it might
influence our uh decision-making factors
brother and sisters the next episode
we're going to be doing is we as men
guessing what woman look for in a
husband and then they're going to come
and tell us so vice versa
inallah do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has helped develop allot
of us it's extremely beneficial
to do this course definitely recommend
this
course to access the free lifechanging
training now okay so today's topic
sisters is in a nutshell we need you
guys inshah tell us what you think a man
looks for in a wife I want you guys to
brainstorm that whatever you think
whatever ideas you have come to a
conclusion you have anywhere from 35 to
40 minutes yes so we're going to leave
the room now so the topic you can start
when you ready you can start now KCK
somebody who's going to take not out
okay let's just brainstorm what men want
in women okay um so he wants to go first
you from there I mean anyone can say
whatever okay I'll just say what I said
before um what I think men want wait
what was it women want men what men want
in a woman what I think what men want in
a woman is uh just her presence her
presence alone is healing her presence
alone is is what nurtures a man to be a
real man that's that's what I believe
anyway because if you really think about
it men have I'm not saying that men have
a harder job but being the providers and
the being the provider and the protector
the world is Harsh um and if the world
is Harsh you want to come home to
someone who is going to is going to re
re-energize you again before you go back
into the world so I think
uh what men want is a nice uh kind
caring
nurturing uh woman who nurtures the good
things about them MH uh that's what I
think what do you guys think yeah I
think this I think it's the same
kindness and even if you look in the
Quran that is one one of the rights of
the man when it comes to marriage is
that the peace and the kindness and the
Tranquility is from the woman and in in
return we you give the respect and you
know when the man is kind to us and
treats us good we give him respect and
all of those other things and like you
touched upon the security and providing
if the woman is not feminine it makes
the man become you know like it's like
it's like it's like let's say if a woman
is like let's say a woman for example a
woman who's hyper
independent um and who's struggling to
let down her God because a lot of people
we talk about hyper Independent Women
and say oh she's she just wants to have
a career and she wants this and she
wants that we fail to realize there's a
there's a huge like there's a
huge barrier which is the fact that she
might have some sort of like trauma like
in in the sense that a man whether
that's her brother her father or a
previous marriage whatever the case may
be has let her down and she felt like I
am not safe in this world I need to
provide for myself so there's a lot of
trauma like there's a lot of trauma
behind it I'm not safe in this world so
I need to to become hyper independent
she's in her survival State when a
woman's in like um when a woman is in
her hyper independent state she's in a
survival State she needs to survive so
let's say a woman who's hyper
independent comes with a man who's also
like let's say masculine it's two like
kind of masculine energy is clashing and
it's just it's not going to work out
obviously um but I don't really know
what I was going with that point but
yeah I'm writing your points you know
what I'm saying just kindness again
attraction I I'm going to touch upon
attraction I would say attraction is
vital I mean a lot of people don't like
to accept it but you know and then want
to fuss and moan about why women got
makeup and stuff if the woman doesn't
look attractive the man's not going to
be ATT one thing I've noticed anyway
with men me um one thing I've noticed
with
men is um they want a woman who looks
after her physical appearance 100% she
looks good even when you're 10 years
into marriage and that's one thing men
really like ego yeah and they like they
like visuals about
girls exactly everything's attraction
espe like just you as like just you no
you're right you know if you you guys
are right if you think about it men are
obviously very visual creatures whereas
whereas women we we're more mentally
stimulated like we we if a man is
intelligent and um masculine and like we
we we get stimulated mentally and that's
what's makes us attracted to men
obviously physical looks is also very
important for women as well but yeah not
so much I think not so much as men
so no you're right we can compromise on
that but for men it definitely is visual
creatures cuz that's that's the yeah and
and you know why it's so
true there was a sister that was looking
for marriage she's she's like maybe now
probably in their 40 she's is still not
married by the way and I remember one
day me and my sisters were sitting with
her and this sister did not make an
effort okay I'm not throwing shade I'm
just saying okay if I was a guy yeah I
wouldn't find it attractive and that's
the God's honest if I had seen her I
wouldn't think oh God yes I want to go
for this do you know what I mean and it
doesn't mean you have to have a plaque
of makeup on or whatever just cream your
face get it nothing just cream your face
you know take care of your g whatever
you got on look good your
clothes sense of effort that's more
attractive than the actual end result
cuz sometimes you know we all have
different levels of beauty and beauty is
actually in the eyes of the beholder and
we might consider a sister to not be
that attractive because of what our you
know competition is between females but
for a male she might be really
attractive and I wish say that being
attractive and being pretty are two
separate things like there are people
that are attractive but when you
actually sit down and think about the
actual makeup of their face they're not
goodlook they're not but they have an
aura they have a sense of Pride and
that's the that gives you the illusion
or gives men the illusion that CH for
example you I have a lot of sisters that
you know maybe go to the gym spend time
moisturizing oh I've got to you know new
perfume Etc because it's the idea that
she's taking care of herself that makes
her attractive she might be less
attractive or pretty because I Define
those as two different things than you
know the next sister that he sees on the
street but maybe that next sister
doesn't look like she looks after
herself in his mind he doesn't have the
top prize he doesn't have the prize
because the best things are looked after
exact so true it's also play on
psychology as well you know um and I
think that's part of when you say want a
goodlooking or attractive a woman they
are two separate things and some men
want actual Beauty in terms of you know
from Allah like natural and you know and
that could be you know some some men
prefer the no makeup and that's the
beauty you know and others actually need
makeup and they don't mind because they
just want something that looks beautiful
so you know depends
attract what they're actually attracted
to is the femin femininity of the woman
so I just wanted to quickly land that in
because what you said it comes out in
different ways yes do you understand but
in actual fact if women are beautifying
theirself creaming their skin taking
care of theel being in a real feminine
energy that comes out beautiful where
regardless you become attracted
regardless natural to a woman as well
you want to look good but if you're
wearing you know men clothes and you're
you're raggedy and you're you know
you've got this big and You' not brushed
your hair for like
you got this like really bad you know um
attitude that's not Fe that's because
you're not in your feminine you know
what I mean and a man's not going to
find that attractive he sees that as a
comp competitor actually you know it's
in the nature to like pick out a woman
who's feminine and who's taking care of
us taking care of herself but I was
going to say to add to what you were
saying um um you know when a woman takes
care of herself like for a man it's it's
like it's like oh she's taking care of
herself to look good for me yes for me
and it's kind of like yeah you're not
you're not obviously you are individual
people but sometimes you know when
you're in a relationship for a really
long time like you're married for a
really you do end up start to end up
seeing that person as an extension of
yourself um and because you see them as
an extension of yourself you you do you
you when they look good you're like yeah
like that's my wife my wife looks good
yeah you know there's also a sense of
selfishness on the male part it's to do
with their ego it's what do you mean by
that in term it means that for example
if you're making him if you're looking
good you're make like you said you're
reflecting on him so it makes him so his
status amongst his PE Rises because it's
it's like he's got the prize you know so
it's it's also a status thing and that's
what I mean by ego you know it's the
same for women when if you know we want
a protect and provider
you know sometimes I mean I guess you
could explicitly say we want someone
that is doing well financially that's
also a sense of prize amongst women and
that's why we compete for for that
generally you know we want that provided
I'm not saying he has to be rich I'm
just saying the provider factor is a
competition you know and that's the
equivalent for males I think it's the
looking after but I was because you're
looking for the ultimate
provider I was going mean I wouldn't say
I wouldn't put
yeah I wouldn't say it's a competition
okay because I I would want best for my
sisters I wouldn't compete with them no
but that's really that's really
honorable sisters sisters we don't
compete with each other
we everyone as well everyone in general
as well cuz obviously we're here to like
a build a like a great um and if we're
going to compete with each other then
like we're going to clash you are your
own competition but the reality is there
is a
competition and it's like the survival
of the fittest amongst the mating world
it's like even animals do it and cre
other creatures and it's just innately
in us it's like it's like even if you
went to an all female event like a
wedding or something each sister will
dress up in the best way possible and
it's not necessarily because she's
competing for a man they're competing
amongst one another innately even if
it's not deliberate to look good you
know like they have a they have a beauty
and that's where you know where there
are sisters for example that are you
know okay and accepting of uh polygamy
for example if you're number three or
number four you don't mind number one
and number two and you see it as you are
competing it's like a competitive
position to be in you know and why is
that maybe the man has something so
great to offer obviously he has to be a
provider and that's what he comes down
to it comes down to you sorry I I get
what you're saying and I think there's a
lot of Truth to what you're saying CU if
I really think about it sometimes you
know let's say you're getting dressed
you're like I want to look the best
today so I know what you're saying
there's there's a lot of truth to it but
I think it can like become a little bit
toxic if if we um if we start like if we
have that mindset of okay I want to look
the best but like but you can't look the
best and like I agree but the reality is
there are
sisters I think it comes down to the
indiv and it's honestly very unhonorable
and it's really good you know for us to
be able to look into that and say hang
on there's no competition here you know
we are all you know beautiful in a
different way but there there are people
that are competing yeah but I think
personally for me like okay I I want to
look really good I want to look the best
for myself but then when I see other
women I think oh my God you look amazing
as well and you look amazing as well let
me just add I I don't think that what
you're talking about it's something you
yourself
yeah that's
true an amazing place to be because by
default us women we don't come like that
we are envious and Jealous by default
never experienced that but but I'm
exactly like you I can see a sistant and
be like M you're so stunning you look
good but I that takes practice and
educating yourself and humbling yourself
but in by default if the woman hasn't
got emotional intelligence she's going
to be jealous she's going to be envious
we see in the we see examples of it in
the prophets wife it's no I agree like
it is in our nature but I guess for the
women um out there who do experience
that it's a natural emotion to feel
don't feel guilty about it but I do want
to say like okay I'll give you like a
tip to help you like mentally if you do
see a woman who looks really good and
you do feel a little bit envious it's
okay but you just tell yourself but I
also look good like like you should tell
you should tell
you know I feel like I feel like it's
this idea of
um I used to compare myself a lot when I
was younger to be honest and it's when
you're like super insecure um we've all
gone through that stage I'm sure all of
us have um but how I see it anyway is
everyone is on their own Journey you
don't know what their story was in order
to get to who like who they are right
now exactly so be happy for their
success and just focus on you and that
mindset has changed me like I I am happy
for whoever their success is but my
focus is always improving I am my own
competition that's how i% so if I'm if
I'm trying to improve myself I look at
okay I look in myself and I look inwards
how do I improve myself inwards yeah
that's how I like to see it yeah yeah so
okay someone attractive not
necessarily someone someone who
basically attract kind okay I wrote it
down ning and femin
we said um a woman in her real feminine
energy so she's soft nurturing caring
kind um speaking to the mic one number
one thing I separated was peace men want
peace peace um a woman's Beauty someone
who takes care of herself she dresses up
can I add a key one which no one really
talks about and it is
fertility men are looking for a fertile
woman even if they don't know it that is
what they're looking for and all those
other things were mentioning
attraction all these other things they
actually look at a woman cuz I actually
was watching a show about the shape of
women as well the shape of women men
would look at the shape of a woman and
say okay she can bear my children she
can carry good children she don't care
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like they don't
even realize they're doing it themselves
they look at a woman and say okay she's
looks like she can carry children she
looks fertile because you remember by
default Allah's created them to
procreate we we're supposed to be
procreating we're supposed to to get
together and make children so ultimately
he's looking for a fertile woman a lot
of people don't discuss it they don't
talk about it fertility is important for
men okay and we don't talk about it
because it's the women who carry the
baby and we're the ones that are
pregnant but the man is the one that
gives us the child so he's essentially
looking for a woman is she going to be a
mother is she can she Nur my kids can
she you know bring her home together so
fertility is definitely on the list for
me is one of the important things that
people just completely Miss for okay
what else guys
I would say goodness oh
sorry um I would say um a man wants um a
woman to listen like as in like if he
has if he's had wife no not like
husband I would I would definitely say
to my husband because if he if he if
he's had like a like a bad day at work
or if he just wants to event like
understanding yeah just yeah
understanding and a good listener like I
would I would do that for him yeah I I
get what she's saying like let's say um
when you say listening I think she she's
basically saying is she he wants to feel
heard like cuz usually if you think
about a masculine man in the real world
they're very stoic you can't really show
much of your emotions you have to like
withhold a lot but then when a man is in
the presence of his wife he becomes like
a child like he becomes like a child and
uh he becomes like his he he can be
himself uh and he can only be himself is
if that woman holds space for uh for him
to be able to be his be himself and
she's understanding and she actually
listens to him like listens to what he
has to say and um can I add something on
H yeah go
on yeah so when I when I say like a good
listener CU I know that men they tend to
not talk about the feelings and they
they're a bit cold with that so me being
a good listener showing empathy towards
him uh would allow him to slowly break
down his like you the patriarchy how
being vulnerable now we're going on to
something that I think it's a Cy the men
are not going to agree with you lot I
don't think want a
woman my opinion no they want to be
vulnerable but what you're saying is
it's very conflicting it's like okay we
want to be vulnerable don't say it no
that only happens with your wife because
with with the prophet peace be upon
him she she was so close to the prophet
peace upon him and he he would Express
his feelings to like was exactly so a
man being stoic is is not as like a I
don't see it as like a really positive
thing I mean I think it's a good thing
there's nothing wrong STM is a good
character could be there's half and half
you can't be fully stoic other it
depends your context yeah yeah because
depends on your context I think it's
really important for a man to be stoic
cuz for you to practice I don't know if
people understand like stoicism is the
art of like someone who doesn't complain
yeah yeah someone who's able to you know
carry out his responsibilities and his
tasks and his daily things that he needs
to do as a man without like moaning and
complaining and and like um finding ways
of like trying to avoid that like cuz I
think I think everything you saying is
actually H yeah it's all facts but then
we're going to go we're going to go into
society cuz I feel like the way we think
as Muslims anyway is completely against
the way society's made us start to think
think so there's this conflict of
agreeing like you're saying no they're
saying but it's it's like okay but
Society has literally programmed us to
not make men men shouldn't be vulnerable
men shouldn't be vulnerable and now
women are kind of real women Muslim
women are like dying for the man to be
back that way yeah like I want my man to
express his emotions to me like no no no
she meant we're dying for masculine men
now we want the man to be like and come
home with like bowels of water and be
like babe you don't need to work but
what Society has made women and men
equal so that the women are the men are
crying at home oh baby I can't can't go
to work I got cold and you get it like
true that put me off Sor we've been
convinced that that's that's normal like
okay the man should be at home crying on
your lap 24/7 the prophet Muhammad Salli
wasn't crying all the time there were
times where he was
legit killing and and and fighting
because he had to the most of the time
he was in his masculine State he wasn't
always vulnerable do you know what I
mean and that time with the when he was
the Quran was first revealed to him he
was that was the first time he was
probably vulnerable to that degree but
that's not men by default so to say like
I want my man to feel like that and
women that's our issue as well why don't
you talk to me tell me what's going on
and the man just like shut up I just
want you to sit here and be quiet
sometimes yeah and let me think this
through and this is why there's this
conflict what society's told us girls
which is fine cuz it's the way you've
been raised you've been you've been
programmed you've been programmed to
believe the man should be at home crying
you know I don't and I'm going to go and
put on my jacket and go to work sorry to
interrupt sorry to interrupt okay I'm
going to give you like a solution okay I
love solution solution okay for all of
us girls in order to find like a really
healthy relationship I think we need to
understand men well they don't want to
be emasculated just off what you're
saying sister is essentially they we're
not saying never be vulnerable obviously
everyone has vulnerabilities but if he's
sharing something he doesn't want to
feel he's IM mascula in himself and he
doesn't want you to react in a in a way
that suggests his imasc so you know and
this is where
the submission aspect comes in as a as a
wife is that you have to recognize where
you're going to submit to him so I think
some times this submission thing
especially in mainstream Society has
been um cast in quite a negative light
oh he submitting to your husband but
submission doesn't mean just doing
anything and everything he wants with
without any other Compassion or elements
to the relationship it means just
recognizing when you have to pipe down
as a female to let him um rise as a male
and vice versa like it's it works both
ways there's going to be times where he
he's going to have to be more
compassionate to you so that you can be
in your femininity you know he's if
let's just talk about the you know the
ideal model where he's um working all
day etc's coming home doesn't want
someone to come home and make him feel
even less of a man that someone might
another man might have made him feel
outside of the household so you have to
pipe down and think let him have his
moment of you know masculinity in the in
the day that maybe he was ex sized by
other men you know so it he needs to
regain um that identity um so this is
why you know it's very important for us
to as wives or females to respect that
need man's need and we talk about men's
needs and we always relate it to uh
intimacy only you know but that is part
of it you know in a grand scheme of
things um so yeah
that's just to like stop and go back to
the question what men want in women um
you guys tell me about what you think
about the points I'm just droing it down
yeah go on so a woman in her real
feminine energy who's soft nurturing
caring kind peace um a woman's Beauty
someone who takes care of her appearance
she dresses up for her man fertility um
and understanding an empathetic wife um
I've also added submissive and respect
yeah those I think those we've covered
things we
didn't really interesting while none of
us actually said religious a religious
wife oh yeah why did no one say
that basic it's a basic
though of every man do you see what I'm
saying I'm glad it's it's like it's like
because I feel like escap goat because
people just go religious man or
religious woman but you need you need to
elaborate that though it really doesn't
it cover everything genuinely we you
know there's been a lot of women who
felt for religious men and um they they
have never worked on themselves they've
never looked inwards they've never
worked on their traumas and they they're
very toxic very toxic and then you they
use religion as a scapegoat to be like
yeah yeah because Islam says so okay but
but you have you really thought about it
do you really know what you're saying
because clearly you don't know what
you're saying because you're using
religion as a scapegoat for all your
problematic behaviors I've I've noticed
that a lot um but yeah is I feel like
yeah I feel like of course a woman a man
does want a woman who's on Dean um for
his children for his children not
necessarily because he a woman is a
school a woman is a school and she's
going to be the first point of contact
with your children like your children
are going to be raised with that woman's
mindset that woman you choose to marry
your children are going to have the same
mindset so it's so so important to look
at so many aspects mindset we forgot
about mindset like a man is going to
look at woman's mindset what's your mind
we do really look for that but sometimes
it's it's genuinely for but high value
men okay if we're going to go into that
topic but girls I've got a question I've
got a question before we go cu the
brother said we got 10 minutes so
everything we've just mentioned okay
yeah how would the brother know just by
looking at a sister that sister she has
all those essential things so now that
helps us get down to just the four most
important things that men look for and
how you going to like how you going to
know her energy and just how she carries
how does one know like I hope the
brothers ask their St this as well how
will you know that that person has all
of those valuable essential assets that
we just you know characteristics and all
these things it's down to him to think
of the right questions but Islam Islam
brings them to that point see you see
somebody you know they're a Muslim from
one it should be you understand that's
the basic atast minim trying to observe
yeah hijab yeah bare minimum and hijab
is different all over the world by the
way of course so I would say Islam is
the top being a Muslim being a religious
person and then from when you can
confirm that that person is a Muslim
then you can go on to the next stage
which is I don't know how people are
finding out who people are and how
they're meeting each other each other
see you know how I see it for men think
about the first man that was created the
prophet Adam yeah and remember he was
lonely in heaven and all he wanted was
just a companion wanted a and that's it
men don't want much women run a lot we
have a lot like we have a lot of re a
good point I like that
point he just wants companionship he
just wants her energy her Aura her
presence is enough like a woman and men
have said that as well just just sit
there this what I mean but women
we we like we nurturers by Nature we
just want yeah we want to nurture things
and so I've got an issue with control
freaks okay females who are control
freaks listen it's too much do you
understand but you know there's a lot of
like trauma behind that as well and I
keep mentioning trauma but there's a lot
of psychological like issues I know but
it's detrimental you work yourself yeah
yeah you have to work on yourself yeah
yeah yeah like do I know myself enough
before and secretly I'll just add I
don't know if he's going to cut this out
psychos as well they want a bit of a
psycho chick a lot of
guys
Jing psych elaborate psycho it's too
broad it is but they do want a bit of
psycho I'm just saying that because of
the kind of messages I read psychos in
just a bit of a challenge but not in a
negative way okay okay right I see it I
see what you mean like a bit of a
challenge they want to work for it for
long I've been trying to behave but the
TRU the one a bit of a I get what you
mean like cuz men they feel like the for
men they obviously they're the ones who
um go through the what do you call it
the vetting process they chase and they
like the chase can I sorry to cut you I
think this is essential before before
before the end the kind of guy we just
described the kind of the man that we
just all spoke about yeah yeah is a man
of Old Times okay interesting the modern
man today this why I said a psycho
because the modern man today his
requirements are far different okay 5050
on tell me do you really want me to say
it I don't know if I can no you say it
but I'm going to say it but PG PG keep
it PG keep okay don't then on okay
unfiltered
so just be you mate they
want this is the truth the mod man today
Muslim or nonm muslim okay a lot of them
want the botox's face yeah this is the
truth the want the boto lips the boto
forehead W this is the hwk this is not
modern this is Shan in in in a hij
that's they want Botox face
no I'm really trying to put this across
I they want the botox face sex a
sandwich maker and a slave and because a
lot of them have this mentality where
this woman is here for my pleasure only
and anyone's been around modern
mentality not saying all of them but
some of the guys majority of them and I
know cuz I deal with them in my DMs and
I deal with them in the comment section
and a lot of them say just go make a
sandwich you're just here for sex this
is the truth this is the Hulk okay the
Muslim man what we just described
doesn't necessarily exist today or he's
under he's hiding away from society it's
the truth and the brothers will probably
say the same about the sisters on the on
the other side because the requirements
for the Sisters as well is insane as
well you know why is
I with themselves we've lost the H you
know why we've lost touch with ourselves
is because we we've lost touch with
sorry it always comes down no I I I get
what you're saying I do think it's a
very like it's a it's an subjective
based thing what you're say and I do see
it and I think if you if you're a man
who watches
pod um and you indulge in stuff that
you're not supposed to be indulging in
you're going to have say watching porn
sorry to you're going to have these
requirements because why even need to
watch porn anymore you just need to go
on IG and porn's just at your doorstep
you know what I mean so
we're in a society where that is being
pushed in your face 24/7 sorry five more
minutes yeah it's been push in their
face that's what I'm saying the modern
man today if we're going to talk about
the Modern Man and what men want today
the men of today that's what they want I
think sandwich maker and a slave but
okay let let me let me add to that
modern man I I I think the reason why
the modern man that you the modern man
that you've exactly that you've
described the this is this is all surf
surface level yeah and if you're going
to be looking for women who have surface
level stuff then you're somebody who's
surface level as well cuz we we attract
who we are and it's the truth I don't
care what anyone says we attract who we
are and if you're CH if you're choosing
surface level things like that
materialistic stuff like that um
superficial stuff like that then then
you have each other yeah because this is
what you this you're most likely a
surface level Muslims and non back in
the day do you think something like this
could be happening us having a podcast
like this with men and women
talking it's not happening but we're in
modern times and we've really got to
understand that and I think we've lost
way of the dean itself the dean was
created and made for every time every
era every generation every we've lost it
completely we've literally lost it
sisters are looking like a Halloween
mask do you know what I mean brothers
and brothers too they're getting these
they're dying their their hair line hair
implants it's gone it's crazy do you
understand so when we're looking at it
look surface level yes but people are
surface level internally and externally
do you know what I mean they don't have
the dean remember what I said about
feeding your feeding your soul a lot of
people don't even pray they don't read
the Quran Bas do the stuff that keeps us
our soul alive do you know so what do
you think is going to happen after a
while you're feeding you're watching um
constantly show on Tik Tok constantly on
Instagram which is a porn
website made us completely what are what
we our preferences become what we are
watching and what we are exposed to I
guess we need to become more conscious
because I feel like I feel like we are
innately conscious beings but we're not
conscious of the things we're consuming
and and the effects of it and and then
but you don't realize the effects until
like I guess later on until the choices
you make okay guys now we need to
actually take a pick for we need four
things I'm going to read out the list
again and yeah go on you obviously have
to agree on it um God conscious Islam um
a woman in her real feminine energy
she's soft nurturing caring kind peace a
woman's Beauty and someone who takes
care of her appearance she dresses up
for him
fertility um and understanding an
empathetic wife she's submissive respect
a good mother companionship I'm going to
take off this list I think I think if
I'm going to be quite honest the most
important ones here and I think I know
the long and they're spanning out to me
definitely respect respectful men r on
about respect def
submissive is going to does respect all
under submission
though category that covers a lot of
aspect so respect respect I'm going to
leave the submissive one because I've
got different opinions on that um and
definitely sub respectful uh religious
fertile um and attractive okay I don't
know my so religious attractive and um
what was the last one um beauty Beauty
yeah I think that's the first one and
we'll agree
together I would say God
Consciousness um a woman in her feminine
energy so soft and nurturing kind caring
yeah um someone who's respectful
cuz Mutual
yeah um I'm a good mother because yeah I
think they just want someone who can
provide them with kids
okay right I would say what a met what
men want in women is feminine feminine
soft and
nurturing um they
want they want um a a a respectful a
submissive wife um a woman who is a good
mother who is also
fertile how many did you say you said
like four okay yeah and companionship
five I'm gonna do a take on what we've
all agreed on and kind of conclude from
there so I think what we're saying
though not necessarily agreeing 100%
just but the key things that we're all
agreeing on um is they're looking for a
mother MH um looking for
respect um
Dean um and
femininity
undery think
okay so guys you have heard the sisters
inshallah you've heard what they had to
say uh we didn't we was in another room
uh and we are going to get them to send
us their results uh halfway through this
so we don't want to know El so it might
influence our uh decision making factors
so in a nutshell Brothers the sisters um
were asked what do they believe a man
looks for in a uh wife uh we're going to
actually tell them what we actually look
for in a wife and then what we're going
to do is we're going to get their and
compare it to ours and be like okay um
is the sisters you know maybe have high
expectations or maybe are they dreaming
uh we're going to find out today
inshallah so let me just open the floor
very simply um what do as men what are
let's see four things we look for in a
wife so every man from Muslim man's
perspective or yeah there might be some
things maybe even non-muslims can agree
so let's start with are you married not
yet okay so let's let's start with in
okay so um what would you as as a how
old are you I'm 25 so 25 actually yeah
so what would you say are the main
things that you look for in a a wife
I'll mention one quality so I don't want
to say the standard things like Dean Etc
cuz that's a that's a given so I'm going
to say I look for shyness in a woman so
okay I'm going to be writing these down
yeah okay
okay okay so I look for shyness in a
woman and what I mean by that is I don't
want someone who's got friends
everywhere male friends everywhere do
you know what I mean if we go to a
restaurant she knows everyone there I'm
looking for someone who's a bit shy
right who understands sort of that
Integrity aspect um that's one of my
main qualities I look for in a
relationship okay and is that the main
thing well main thing is going to be
Dean isn't it but that's mention three
things to me three things okay so so I
do want someone who's a bit sort of
career focused as well so that's another
thing right have some sort of ambition
anything career Focus business some sort
of thing to have on the side just to
give them a bit of you know ambition
essentially that's what I'm attracted to
um third thing is obviously Dean that's
number one priority essentially um so
having that sort of eagerness me and the
brother next I was I was speaking to him
earlier about it having that sort of um
sort of that eagerness to learn about
Islam um Salah the main thing um so
things like that so I'm looking for the
three main things okay um M well what
would you say um is a man's criteria do
you mind if I uh the question the
brother get some clarity so you
mentioned um my my twin by the
way it's very strange for me to say m i
very I rarely say it so you mentioned
just now that you would like your wife
to be to be career
focused I have two questions number one
why number two how do you know that you
want her to be career focused so you're
me a career let me provide more clarity
to the question what's your experience
of being married to a career focused
woman so one I can't give experience
with that cuz I'm not married never have
been okay but essentially what I mean
about career focused is doesn't
necessarily mean you know she needs to
go out 37 and a half hours a week what I
want is to have some sort of ambition a
business on the side anything even our
profits wives had businesses on the side
that's why I'm attracted to some sort of
ambition so you mentioned you're
attracted to it what by the way I don't
have a problem with this I'm just trying
to get clarity what makes you attracted
to that what is it about that that
attracts you to that yeah and I
understand so with that with career job
that sort of stuff I sort of apply
intellect with that so I think it's it
goes hand in hand so when I see someone
who's got a a good job safe job high
paying job there's progression in there
I like that I'm attracted to it in a
sense where I know they've worked hard
to get there they've got that sort of
discipline to get there it's an example
of something to look for if she doesn't
have that what is that indicative to you
what do you fear she might be or not be
if she does have these uh this skill
that you've mentioned so for me it's not
it's not sort of black and white it's a
sort of there's many factors with this
right but if she doesn't have any sort
of ambition in that aspect I don't think
she's as hardworking as I like her to be
to be honest with you so why do you want
her to be hardworking again it sounds
like an accusatory question it's not I'm
just trying to understand what do you
want her to be hardworking for what's
the end goal the end value that you get
yeah the the end goal is J for everyone
isn't it you know it's heaven for for me
on a personal on a personal level it
shows to me that she's worked hard for
something you know what I mean and I
understand do you think you're
conflating a ambition with career like
because you know it's very we have this
um propaganda tool of career do you
think you're talking about somebody who
has a drive who has an ambition uh but
do you think you're just Mis equating it
making it synonym to ker if a if a woman
is for example smart she comes to you
and says you know what um I did my
degree in math mathematics um I do not
want to work I want to be a housewife
again she still got that degree she's
still work
it's not that you w a career it's
basically somebody who's gone out there
done something has something it's clever
what do you think do you think he's
coming from there it's confing the I I
honestly I don't know I don't know
that's why I'm trying to get clarity and
don't think I'm like put I'm not putting
you under the C bro but I always try to
get clarity before I provide my answer I
want to understand either what what
value do you get from that or what do
you fear she will not have if you marry
a woman who doesn't possess these
qualities one of the two you're looking
to either seek a value from her of some
sort or you fear she might have
something that you don't like what is it
which one and what is it so for me in
that aspect I don't want a woman to have
100% Reliance on me I want some sort of
level of Independence on the woman's
side okay that's the gist of it so when
you say 100% Reliance do you mean from a
Bill's perspective or do you mean from
an emotional perspective no just not
even from a Bill's perspective I'm happy
to provide it's more of a sense of
having your own thing going on the side
for me I'll have I'll have a job I'll
have things that I do outside of the
marriage I want her to have qualities
like that where she can have her own
independence time away from me Etc I'm
glad I asked all of those questions
because I'm in agreement with you there
you go and it's very important for your
woman to have her own little thing going
on because otherwise the bordedom will
kill her and who's going to who's going
to be project onto the man yeah you'll
be picking up that slack so in that case
I agree with you okay good so guys I
think we have about maybe under 30
minutes um so the first the first thing
is we said okay modesty uh you mentioned
should like Korea should we use another
word ambition ambition that's fine so um
what's the three things that you look
for in a
woman Allah says in the
Quran and from his sence is that he has
created from you uh wives such that you
so that you may find peace in
her so Allah has already descried in the
Quran one of the major qualities that we
are we are able to receive from a wife
and that is peace especially if you are
a man who is hardworking you don't have
to be by the way high value man bin men
are hardworking yeah plumbers are
hardworking a hardworking man yeah blue
color white color is irrelevant what
does he want to come home to after his
hard working day peace he doesn't want
to come home to a war zone for me after
the dean and when I say Dean I'm not
looking for no she prays five times a
day and she wants to get better in her
religion she has that eagerness there
that's enough for me then peace can you
be peaceful
alhamdulillah okay that's I think the
word peace is um very very vital which I
I would agree with as well from just
obviously I'm the host but I would just
like to add on like to me it's obviously
the dean the dean should be there peace
is fundamental it it is so fundamental
because we as men uh with our masculine
traits we deal with all this chaos and
you know uh whatever is for what angle
do you get what I'm trying to say um and
we want to come home to peace um and
I've said this before like I've
confronted you know the Britain first
Jada do you remember her y just I always
say this to myself I was like can you
imagine I come back home to another Jada
just imagine I'm I'm confronting Jada
I've got all that headache okay try and
then I come home there's another Jada we
at home yeah I don't want that bro I
want I want peace yeah so peace is very
fundamental and modesty and de for me
personally but uh Aki for you what was
the three things that you would um say
that you look for three things that you
look for in in a in a wife and men look
for as well um you know I think I was
looking for four things uh we didn't say
how many wives you want we
meant so why why do you tell the truth
it's the bit of truth bro tell the truth
in if my wife is watching she knows the
truth
too no no no in for but for anything
else for things yes that I would look
for yes
one there has to be emotional
compatibility
right I have to have someone that I can
emotionally connect with I have to have
someone that I can intellectually
connect with that me and her we're on
the same mental level if I'm talking
about one thing and she's
completely alien to what I'm discussing
then we're never going to be able to
connect
I have to have someone that I can
spiritually connect with that on our
journey together that she accepts and
respects my leadership in our spiritual
growth and also there has to be someone
that I can physically connect with so
these will be my four main things
physical spiritual emotional and
intellectual okay brother for me uh
alhamdulillah it's first is Dean
everyone knows but peace is very
important but I personally think the
important thing is loyalty you need a
wife to stand by you no matter at good
times or bad times she sticks by you and
be there for you not like when she's
there with you at good times and when
the bad time comes and now she turns
away like you know that's a very very
important um thing in a marriage because
there's loads of women there that when
the hard time comes and then they don't
stick by you so for me me a loyalty a
woman who sticks by me at the good times
and the bad time for me is very very
important in a marriage okay um so
there's some few things I've written
here so we've Wroten we've written I've
written modesty Dean ambition loyalty
peace three of us I think agreed we the
word the word peace is something that
resonates with all of us emotional
connection now when it comes to
emotional connection spirital connection
that's a bit more um I think we're
talking more about individual aspects I
want to talk a bit more general what me
look for like can we agree that every
man wants to
um uh wants somebody a woman that's
feminine can can we can we AG because I
think I don't want to go into the nties
of I prefer this I want to make it a bit
more Broad and a bit more General um in
that aspect um so does every man should
we say that for example what what would
we put at the top of that list we've got
let's say four what can we because we
need to agree what is the thing that
every man will be like this without this
is not happening what would that be well
Dean essentially that's the main thing
we all picked up on that without Dean
you can't have a successful marriage I
don't think so really I think in general
in general men will place a lot of value
on a woman's looks a looks 100% And if
she's not goodlooking no matter how
Pious she is I think men will be like so
this sacrifice I might be wrong I did
mention this before I said um on the
last episode that men do look for looks
a lot right and I think you're correct
in assuming that on a general BAS that's
a totally different thing though it
because if you're going to marry her
you're going to make her your wife of
course you're going to go for her looks
but then after that everything else
therefore then there's no no no I agree
with what he's saying we need to be real
with ourselves yeah okay and even if you
think about the matter of looks it's
important for us because we live at an
age where it's a bit mad yeah uh so
looks is important because it helps you
to lower your gaze it helps you to be
content with your life and especially
living in in in an age where there's
certain things that are taboo etc for
example if a man wanted to get married
again there's a whole chaos who so it's
very important for you to be content
with your wife but what I'm saying is
like the look are important but you're
not going to like what we look for a
wife of course is going to be you have
to be attractive to her to marry her
okay good so so so so this is why it's
important okay so Dean look okay let's
let me make it if you had somebody who
is absolutely religious Quran you name
it yeah she's she's carrying Quran with
everywhere yeah she is not goodlook when
I say good-look to you would you marry I
would Mar correct I want to be real here
yeah cuz in my marriage seeking process
uh yes there were sisters who were
really religious but not to my liking
yes so therefore I I I have to be real
and not act Pious and be like no had so
looks play a role so Dean look if I met
a sister who was dropped dead gorgeous
like beautiful yeah but she had no Dean
again to me yes I would have to fight my
little sh here like you know yeah you
know you might you might teach
the Ali I got a question for you okay so
the thing is all right a girl can be
beautiful but what about her character
soon as you talk to her and a girl can
look beautiful when you look at her but
her character is so bad that but that's
the first
thing the first thing men look at is
looks and then everything else come is
like's corre do we agree mat as well you
I don't know sorry I don't know one one
over here no
that's so uh Aki so I'm saying a
nutshell when we look at a potential is
it Dean first or looks first because I
believe like for me personally it would
be like I have to be attracted to her
then the second thing is Dean if the
dean is not there it's not happening so
it doesn't mean the the beauty in itself
is going to do do it for me can we agree
is it Dean first or Beauty First in that
sense but actually worked simultaneous
Dean can come afterwards can't
it true you have to be a certain amount
of Dean all I'm saying if you meet if
you're religious yourself and you like
you know and you meet a woman that is
attractive and she's got some of the
dean in her but when you get married to
her your relationship the way you are
your Dean will get stronger together
true true that a potential but it can
happen it goes based to the character
but Dean in like if somebody's not
praying the Salah I do not care how
beautiful you are if you're not given
the rights of Allah subhana tala you not
going to you're not going to give me my
rights give Allah's rights so to me I
would say um can I write the top list
Dean and Beauty can we agree on that I
would say the following and that is I'm
assuming the majority of your audience
are the the the men who will be watching
are men who are not married because if
you are already married and we're
talking about second third and fourth
wife I will give you a different answer
does she have to have Dean no she
doesn't have to have Dean does she have
to want Dean yes she has to want Dean
meaning there are a number of sisters
out there for whatever case they're in
an environment that is not conducive
towards them practicing the religion and
they are inherently weak women are
easily LED this way or that this is why
as a Muslim man you can marry a
Christian or a je but not vice versa cuz
women typically are the ones who are LED
and she's in an environment that is not
conducive to her practicing the dean but
she wants to she acknowledges and
recognizes I want to do better I just
like I need that guy to to give me that
final push because she's in an
environment where she feels she can't do
it herself this is a very positive
indication and quality okay this is
we're talking about for first wife now
cuz second third four I'll give you a
different answer completely does she
have to have Dean no I'll tell you
straight up she doesn't let's get to the
first wife so
exactly so does she have to have she
doesn't have to have it but she has to
want it and if you if you apply this
when you're dealing with sisters I'm
guar I guarantee you to the young single
brothers who are watching you're going
to expand your pool of of of potential
elgible bachelorettes Available to You
CU a lot of brother brothers are looking
for the ready-made sister she doesn't
exist you need to look for the core
ingredients and then it's on you to bake
the cake it's on you to assemble the the
the wife to your to your liking so to
speak but the thing is like with me I'm
the perfect example because my wife is a
Reaver she wasn't Muslim when I met her
I done everything right my acts and
action um made her interested in Islam
and we we practiced together I wasn't a
good Muslim myself so we practiced
together to become better Muslims and we
still practicing so that's yes in that
instance you're absolutely right for
example you went on that journey
together yeah uh but for example like
for myself I that's that's an exception
because if I met a sister who was a
revert yeah and she wanted to know I
would never I would as long as she's
saying I want to learn all day every day
yeah even if it comes like I'll be
honest with you even if it comes she
doesn't wear the hijab and she's like I
would like to as long as the character
and the willingness is one to be that's
fine so we're talking about those who
don't have the willingness so should we
say beauty and Dean two things that I
just want to pick up on that point that
the brother just said um I think there's
a there's a boundary though I think a
lot of people in my generation they put
too much emphasis on when they get
married then they'll become religious
they'll have too much dependency on the
other to help them get religious at the
end of the day it's between you and
Allah you can't rely solely on someone
else to push you through and become on
Dean let me expand on that point because
I actually dealt with the sister once
who actually said this to me I was
considering her for marriage and she
said to me after after we get married
then I'll wear hijab I said to her I'm
not feeling this Vibe or your attitude
towards it what do you mean no no but
after the wedding m
what is it you want to do you want to
have a big fat wedding and and all of
that I didn't I didn't like that but if
she if the if the vibe is you know what
brother I know I need to do better
believe me I really want to do better I
know I'm messing up this is a positive
indication that she's just weak and that
if you are stronger than her in your IM
which you should be by the way I get
confused when brother say to me I want
my wife to guide me separate discussion
but if your Iman is just a little bit
stronger than hers you will be that you
will give her that final push yeah again
though the I understand what you're
saying with the problem with that is if
two weak people with weak IMS they they
won't be able to help each other they'll
probably fall into a big thing is with
that type of thing men nowadays I don't
think but I think a man has to be the
stronger person yeah man has to lead in
that so the thing is a man is weak and
he's trying to get with a weak woman
then is not a good match is that they're
just going to stay the same okay so so
so far we've got two guys our time is
kind of running out um so Beauty and
Dean number one um I think let's Dean on
there and then Beauty I don't want the
sisters to all like cuz when they hear
this beauty thing they like man they get
this like next level anxiety but this is
very important because we have to
there's a thin line because you right I
don't want them to feel like oh you see
this is the reason and sister sadly
that's the reason why they're so easily
influenced you say be or attraction
we're attraction attra so we would say
Dean first and then attrac this meaning
that for example we all would agree that
if there's someone that's really on Dean
but they not attracted to them you would
not marry them yeah we agree with that
and I think Vice ver says it as well um
okay so then we've got Dean we've got
attractiveness what is third in the line
where you're like okay this is vital
yeah and let's not conflate um can we
say someone on Dean is modest can we say
that not necessarily okay so then what
about modesty like like ha like yeah I
mention that I agree with that I
personally think um I don't know loyalty
is a massive thing you don't the thing
is like you can have you can loyalty be
simultaneous with modesty because it
is can we I think they're two separate
what do you think loyalty and modesty I
think they're two separate traits to be
honest with you loyalty covers so much
more than just um just modesty to be hon
because you want you want you want a
wife to stick by you like the hard times
and the good times you don't just don't
want a wife that who's uh attractive and
who prays and when the hard time comes
and she's not I agree with you I'm going
to give you a parable that might shift
even though I agree with you yeah I'm
not in disagreement with you I'm going
to give you a parable that might shift
your your mindset on this and that is
let's say you work for a company you're
an employee at this company you find out
that the company has 6 months left of
payroll and then the 95% likelihood
they're going to go bankrupt I have to a
question for you and you can choose
option A or option b option A you'll
ride or die and you're going to stick it
through to the end come hell or high
water whether they there is a job for
you afterwards or not doesn't matter
option b is you're going to start
applying for jobs elsewhere whilst
you're applying you continue working for
the current job which option you going
to take ride or die to the end or start
applying for jobs elsewhere to just to
be safe
the thing is I can't really like company
situation and life situation comp
they're not they're not the same thing
expain to you why is comparable and the
reason why is this in a company
situation although it's a different
example and I don't just I I let me just
make it I'm not excusing women who do
this by the way because you're right
there is a slight difference but I'm
trying to make you understand they are
the more vulnerable of the two between
you you are the the quote unquote leader
what does that make her the follower you
are the captain what does that make her
one of the I don't know the guys on the
ship whatever you want to call it not
demeaning her level what I'm saying is
is that when you are the one being led
and you sense weakness or impending doom
in your leader you are going to feel a
certain level of anxiety and lack of
security and in the example that I gave
you you will start applying for another
job now am I giving women C BL to start
applying for another job with their h no
I'm not but I am saying I understand why
the thought would creep into her mind
possibly because they are the vulnerable
of the two in the relationship she's
trusting you to lead her as far as she
can see there's no payroll in six months
time what she going to do I'm pregnant
or I got your kids and we're not going
to have no money maybe I need to start
looking elsewhere this is why so a lot
of women do end up quote unquote monkey
branching elsewhere because of this she
is the one who is in the subordinate
position in the relationship and I'm not
excusing her I don't I don't excuse this
Behavior if her husband is doing his
best and he's really trying she needs to
like that the de comes in the way that
we you know every test comes from Allah
and if you if this is your test so if
she doesn't want to go through that's
her choice I agree I'm just just just
the female experience that's it so okay
all right so what's what's the third are
we going to go with um what was it
loyalty
or I think modesty for me I'm going to
I'm going to say what I think is
important um after the after
um Beauty um it is cleanliness and how
she manages the
house now if you are married to a woman
that's
unhygienic and she isn't looking after
the home then no matter how much peace
you're getting if you've been fighting
with J during the day and you come home
to a pig sty I pref I prefer that all a
Jada all day every day P yeah I prefer
that all of Jada because you know what
that I can can clean up there's a
solution to that cleaning up but there's
no solution for J but then here's the
thing here's the thing if for if you
come home no no that's fine that's fine
personally for me if it's not clean and
it's um there isn't there's I think from
the majority of men that I've spoken to
that I deal with there is and you have
kids if you're going out to work there's
an expectation that this is your duty
that's that's
haker motherhood that you know what that
can be taught easier than loyalty and um
and modesty in my opinion it's a
character trainera okay guys we need we
okay look peace is something we spoke
about so the third one is it loyalty or
peace cuz peace is I'll be honest I
think a lot of men want peace like a lot
of men it's just it's just look I just
want
peace peace would come with loyalty
would they
both peace peace yeah okay look I write
peace down yeah okay that's fine what's
number four we might have five well two
more two more yeah so what's two more
things that and let's make it more
General let's not go to the like like
you said cleaning Etc which is true but
these are the some men might be like
okay I don't really mind we're talking
about core core values um I I think an
important thing is when your wife makes
an effort with you like you know she
looks good she was trying to look after
herself for you you know like but that
comes under attraction
yeah yeah yeah exactly so we need one or
two more so what like we've got we
talked about modesty um is does that
fall under de
modesty it's um P
appr if she appreciates you yeah exactly
that's an important one appreciation
gratitude for especially for the
majority of men who are doing their best
and you know maybe his best is not as
much as she wants but that GR gratitude
that's a big
one yeah gratitude
gratitude okay gratitude okay that's
that's that's actually very important
because you know why gratitude is sadly
it's it's it's a trait the prophet
mentioned that woman have is very
important because think about a man
working hard is and he's trying his best
and he comes home and his wife tells him
what are you doing he not good enough
exactly good good good see now we're
talking about C you get it so this is
this is gratitude is fundamental not
only that the prophet talked to the
woman and told them that the the reason
why majority of them were in the
Hellfire is because of the in gratitude
because they were ungrateful to their
husbands you know um so in that aspect
it shows that there's a character issue
there which they need to work on you
know so gratitude okay the last one so
we've got Dean Beauty peace and gra I
think this is good these are this is
good one any one last thing that you
guys would add on there one last loyalty
is quite powerful on that you know that
if you're looking at all of these I
think loyalty actually carries quite a
lot of weight yeah it does loyalty is
very I think in the marriage loyalty is
a big big massive thing it it does carry
weight I think it covers a lot of basis
loyalty it doesn't mean she's going to
cheat it just mean scking and a woman
who doesn't who doesn't gossip a lot
agree because the thing is is that she
can I think you're right like even if
she has Dean it doesn't mean that she
has loyalty right it should Inspire
loyalty but often it doesn't you right
exactly yeah because but then again the
argument could be that how far can she
go before she jumped ship right so
that's the whole different question but
overall I think that's something that
you expect if you're the captain of the
ship that your crew are with you okay
good should we find out the results from
the sisters and see what they they had
in mind okay um do we get price we got
the most right yeah let's see free
holiday
Ty can you ask ask let me let me go let
me go get my wife okay so guys um since
we are reacting to we have more time so
here's what they wrote they wrote
that they believe we look for Dean we
look for uh
respect why didn't we write respect
that's a good one why didn't we say
respect yeah we plug in somewhere Dean
respect peace mother I don't know what
that means mother motherhood family they
wrote a woman who is in her feminine
energy soft nurturing caring and
kindness dress up for the man and takes
care of the appearance okay so that's
looks okay so that's interesting we got
Dean there peace is there that's good
but we we didn't we didn't put respect
and to be honest as men is isn't respect
the like us is like that comes with
gratitude I going to say so they kind of
they're similar okay so that's
interesting so they they have written
the dean which is we got they got right
respect gratitude um Peace that's good
man they've done different so I was
expecting some L I'm not I'm not Jing I
was exping like yeah you know but
anyways so what do you guys make out of
that so do you believe the sisters today
are kind of in check with the realities
of what men want
or doing this episode H some sisters are
some AR it just depends it's Case by
case now isn't it okay so let's say
we're speaking to these these sisters
who are watching this yeah cuz I'm sure
they're going to be watching this yeah
um what would you say to them to look
for in their future future husband four
three things or that you would give to
them because with with they've written
their results which is I'm actually very
surprised it's very close to what we are
looking for so uh they are kind of in
tune I thought they were out of tune ald
they're quite the sisters may Allah
bless what would you say to um the
sisters that are watching this who are
maybe looking for other
stuff um you know I think today that
there is so much pressure
on men and women in society to to almost
break a family up that I think there's
like a war on family today yes right and
that for sisters when they're looking
for a potential spouse they have to look
for someone that's going to provide real
leadership now there's a lot of men like
for example I think most of us are here
our fathers right if you're a father and
you're a man you can immediately
see a man that's not really 100 you know
like he's trying it that's why you're
the guardian right you can see right
through him that he's coming in and he's
putting on a show Because deep down he's
not secure we can see that all of us as
fathers we can see straight away and we
will know when we see a man whether he's
going to be able to look after someone
he might not be there but he's got that
potential because he's secure or he's
grounded then you can see others that
are trying to fake it like they are we
can see through them too right so I
think it's really important for sisters
to have what if they can a good
relationship with their fathers and if
not a good relationship with a male
Guardian that they trust and like older
brother or someone that
can you know check another guy so I
think that's really primary that's what
Islam is
y um what what men women need to find in
man is it no basically what advice would
you give to like sisters because the
expectations here these sisters M
they're on point but if there's a sister
out there what do you think what what n
would you give her to look into in a man
like a couple of things um important
thing is Dean and his character what
kind of character he has how he carries
himself um how he talks is he respectful
and um the people around him who hangs
around where he hangs around uh what he
does you know what I mean all them
things and that will show his character
what kind of person but the thing is
this doesn't guarantee the person
because he might be like a lot of people
put act on and say who they are what
they are then after marriage they're
totally different person but you have to
do your best to do your research don't
walk into something and thinking that oh
you know like he's a good looking guy
and just walk into it with blind and
just mess yourself up so I'll say every
time if you want to go into a marriage
do your research properly but his
character and his Dean is very very
important and who he hangs around and
what he does yeah I think the prophet
said that when he came to look for
someone Dean and the character is very
fundamental a lot of say make that
misjudgment off he looks righteous Pious
but the character is so flawed it's
disgusting character uh which is vital
yep um mthi number one yeah um so yeah
what the brother said sort of safety
security to ensure you know your home's
going to be there your family's going to
be there if you if you're married to a
man who's constantly job hopping doesn't
have a job um you've got no sense of
security and safety there um another
Point as well I'd like to make is uh
confidence look for a man with
confidence and I say that confidence in
the right in the right things so I don't
mean confidence when you're just
chatting for day days you know making
funny jokes this and that I mean
confidence in your Dean confidence to
take control of the relationship to say
you know what you want to do what you
think is right be a leader essentially I
think a lot of men lack that in this
generation true true yeah Matthew what
would you speaking to Young sister who's
I would say where most
uh where most individuals go wrong
especially in the Muslim Community when
it comes to
marriage is uh they go about procuring
too much
information they talk for too long they
meet too many times they go too deep and
then they discover each other's flaws
familiarity breathes contempt and when
you are not
tied by marriage to have to figure it
out you're like there must be someone
else better out there and the truth of
the matter is we are all flawed we all
have things that are dislikable all of
us what you're looking for are the core
ingredients are the core ingredients
there alhamdulillah pull the trigger and
don't spend forever talking and I have a
rule when it comes to if I'm to consider
marrying a sister maximum I will meet
her three times usually I don't even do
that now maximum first time is just
assessing General compatibility I'm not
looking to go into any deal breakers or
things like that just is there chemistry
no point in talking about deal breakers
if I haven't even established if I like
you or not what are we even doing second
conversation will be okay now we need to
find out what are the expectations here
that's where we go a bit deep third
meeting is just when when we're getting
married and that's it too much
information is bad information this
texted backwards and forwards and DM
and not only is it haram to be honest
with you but you're actually sabotaging
your chances of getting married very
true but uh brother me I just need to
ask you you know you said about like
people meet up but do you think it's so
easy that people get divorced nowadays
because they think grass is green on the
other side you know what I mean like
nowadays you know like know back in the
day when people used to get married used
to be like let's work on this less less
you know if they had a problem at home
they would work on it but nowadays if
they have a little argument they split
up people have commitment issues at the
moment they can't stick to you know
there's there's a deep rooted issue but
I mean this could potentially take us to
another discussion how much time do we
have not much uh we can maybe discuss
that another time but you want to add on
yeah I mean it's a longwinded answer
but it's fine because we're reacting to
them but to answer your question is that
so as Ali pointed out earlier Al that
the majority of divorces are initiated
by women women are neurotic by Nature
know this when the going gets tough even
a little bit tough I want to leave or
whatever a lot of women have this
tendency yeah your job as a man is to
you be that wall that where her
emotional waves crash on right and I
have
found that and just to juxtapose what
I'm about to say with like I'm not
talking out my backside alhamd by
Allah's permission firstly and
foremostly any any good I have is from
him and he can take it away from me as
quickly as he gave it to me so this is
not me polishing my own halo but I'm
just OB so the the audience know I've
been married for nearly 20 years
alhamdulillah six of those years in
polygyny I have eight children of my own
three orphans and I also have a number
of wives alhamdulillah and the one frame
that I have found to be the most
effective in not just attracting but
maintaining women and the small circle
of men that can count on one hand who
also have multiple wives in their if you
like is do what you got to do whatever
that is with regards to work and
responsibilities and after that you'll
deal with your wife when you are running
from Pillar To Post trying to please her
chasing after what is it that you want
who cares what she wants she doesn't
know what she wants this is what you you
know what she wants she wants you to
take the lead do what you got to do at
work and then come home sweetheart we're
going out y let's go out let's have some
fun whatever the case may be but when a
man is constantly his frame of reference
is what makes her happy that changes
from that's a moment to moment thing
that that's that's like it's a fleeting
and it's
passing it's interesting look I have I
have a lot of differences with many
people here yeah and um but that's
theing a lot of people would listen to I
I have to agree to that you know um you
know not going into into my personal
life but you know I've I've been a
Muslim for 10 years um I've had a j of
10 years and um even in the de like even
Rob's got he for this so if you look at
the dean the dean is actually the wife
pleasing the husband it's not vice versa
this doesn't mean you oppress your wife
we're not talking about that what we're
talking about is our sisters a woman in
their nature their emotional beings
there's instability there they need
somebody who can take the lead and
that's correct when we're out there
working for our family like I said
before I think Andrew T said this as
well we don't go out there with the
ambition of I'm going to wake up in the
morning go through AB CD and all these
obstacles to come home and oppress my
wife no I'm going there to give her the
the life insh but it's not at the thing
of if you try to go and please your wife
like oh whatever she wants she and the
state might sound a bit misogynistic
whatever but sometimes she doesn't know
what she exactly wants you know it's
it's it's in their nature you need to
understand do we know not this phrase
like for example when a woman say yes it
means no no okay so it's very clear that
in their biology they have they they
they they do they will never tell you
directly what they want the one
underlying quality yeah the one
underlying quality that I have found of
men who are able to attract and maintain
women without any problem and they
typically have multiple at the same time
and I include myself in that statement
is that not one single one of them ever
asked what makes her happy not one of
them ever concerns himself with what
makes her happy does that mean he wants
to make her unhappy no he wants her to
be happy but he doesn't make it his
primary concern his Prim these men are
typically very very busy they hardly
even see their families but then when
they see let's go we're going out we
going to have some fun he doesn't
concern himself with this question in
the first place that's not his
orientation his orientation is I have to
take care of these responsibilities
which are heavy on my head take care of
that and then we're going to go and
we're going to have fun there's a
question what about if he's not dealing
with his
responsibilities and therefore she is
unhappy and then he's escaping so
neither is he fulfilling his actual
responsibilities nor is he considering
whether she's happy or not because he's
like come on let's go out and she's like
well
we've got all of this that you haven't
dealt with he's like no no I don't care
because I'm the man because in his
framework he's not a man he's a boy of
course but then we are living in a
society today where men don't know how
to be men right we're living in a
society where women and this feminist
movement is so strong that for a man to
be less manly and more soft and so on
and argue himself into like avoiding his
responsibilities he's like well I've
become the leader now so how do you deal
with that so so you're right that's a
whole different topic in the sense where
you're right we're talking about men who
give their responsibilities the men that
you talking about are like I said before
whenever we talk about these topics the
sisters always come into their head of
this vile crazy individual we're not
talking about that we're talking about a
man who gives his responsibilities is
good to his family uh Etc but he's a
leader like like like myself I believe I
try my best in my ability to lead my
household but does that mean I don't
listen to my wife I would so if I listen
to my wife she might have some conc okay
good let me listen to it I'll listen to
it and I will categorize and prioritize
them yes I'm not going to go and be like
okay she wants this ah no no no I'm
going okay here okay you've told me okay
do you get I'm
saying men who are fulfilling I just
want to make one thing clear when when
we say a women wants a a leader don't
mean that we mean that women should have
a boss it doesn't mean you're boss it
mean you're leader leader of the House
you make the decisions the decision is
yours the last decision comes at the
house house when you discuss with your
wife you make the decision because
you're the leader of the house and a lot
of people might think that ah he's
trying to be a boss no that's totally
different thing you're leader of the
house that's why you're the husband and
you have the last word that you say yeah
we do this and we do that you know what
I mean because a lot of women would
twist that he's saying he's a leader
wants to be a leader but he's trying to
be the boss no you're right I 100% agree
with you but the sisters need to also
realize that they need to pick their
let's let's call it a boss pick your
boss either like you don't have no
problem going to a career and your boss
tells you to do ab BC D but when it's
your husband who loves you and cares for
you die for you your boss will suck you
in an instant byebye he doesn't care
about oh my kids I don't care sorry
you're not doing the job for me but
that's another topic but in concluding
some other topic and also it's
interesting that I'm very impressed that
we have had three things that we picked
at the sister pick which shows aldah
we're in tune alhamdulillah so um
brother and sisters the next episode
we're going to be doing is we as men are
we are as men we are going to be um
guessing what woman look for in a
husband and then they're going to come
and tell us so vice versa inah you can
watch the episode uh probably after this
uh to my next time BR sister from B
truth show thanks Our Guest may Allah
bless him
in